good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs either through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the foyer please don't please do not
use the lifts please assemble in holy
square on the green offices will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber the Proceedings of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
any member of the public who object to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent and that there and
that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst this meeting is in progress
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
are there any apologies for absence
Bridget I'm Simon day the council died
gender item two minutes of the previous
meeting held on 7th of December 2017 I
move that the minutes of the meeting of
the Council held on 7th of December 2017
be approved in signed as a correct
record would the vice chairman please
second second in madam chairman do
members agree thank you
agenda item 3 minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 18th
of January 2018 I move that the minutes
of the extraordinary meeting of the
council held on 18th of January 2018 we
approved in signed as a correct record
would the vice chairman please ii
seconded madam chairman do members agree
thank you
agenda item 4 announcements I have not
been informed of any announcements
agenda item 5 declarations of interests
are there any declarations of interest
agenda item 6 treasury management
strategy statement an annual investment
strategy mid-year review report 2017 to
18 I call upon councilor townand thank
you madam chairman this report is
required in accordance with the CIP fa
code of practice on treasury management
this report was considered by the
governance and audit committee on the
6th of December 2017 and agreed by
cabinet on the 16th of January 2018 I
move the council approves this
recommendation
is there a second second chair
oh sorry counsel Gregory would you like
to speak thank you just just a few
comments as usual and interesting
treasury management report sir madam
chairman detailing the council's
performance as of the end of last
September four months is a long time in
treasury management and I would prefer
to be approving performance reports much
closer to the actual wind day I have to
say since then of course the financial
situation has moved on with a boring
need for example increased by at least
1.6 million plus further costs in the
port the Bank base rate predictions were
interesting to look back on the latest
predictions been that there will be two
further increases in the bank rate base
rate this year this must give members an
indication of the difficulty of
predicting interest rates and investment
income when you look at the table in 2.1
of this report the capital october
forecast that showed the bank rates
remain in stable at naught point two
five percent until June 2019 however in
their economic updates in the Annex one
section 1.3 has a much greater detail on
the predicted changes and it accurately
predicts a series of interest rate rises
which we are now seeing as of the news
today is coming true this certainly
shows the value of external financial
reports of account that sari advice to
the council in section 4.4 we're told
that the westwood spine road is now
classified as a current liability this
2.5 million ot Kent County Council was
originally only deferred to 2014 and I
wonder if the cabinet member finance can
throw any light on how long KCC are
likely to allow this to continue the
Treasury team had to be congratulated
for exceeding the benchmarks for
investment return but 1s2 asks why the
investment income budgeted at three
hundred and thirty thousand for the year
was already seven hundred and ninety
thousand by mid-year more than double
and obviously can't be attributed to
changes in the interest rates
I found that section 8.1 interesting as
it talks about a sip for exercise to
focus on how local authorities should
report to members on non Treasury type
investment returns it would be useful to
know what proportion of capital
investment return is generated from
property ownership it's widely known
that the returns on property investment
can be much higher than investments with
financial institutions and I look
forward to seeing how they sit for code
develops I finished madam chairman by
saying on behalf of our group how much
we appreciate the professionalism of the
Treasury team in successfully steering
the council's finances who are
constantly changing financial climate
thank you do members agree with the
treasury management statement
seconded madam chairman thank you do
members agree thank you
agenda item 8 budget 2018 to 19 a
medium-term financial strategy 2018 to
2022 I would advise that in accordance
with council procedure rules 17.6 I will
call for a recorded vote on the motion
or any amendments and substantive
motions
I call upon councilor Townend thank you
madam chairman
this report presents the budget for the
general fund housing revenue account
capital budgets and treasury management
strategy for the financial year 2018 to
2019 it was approved by cabinet on the
16th of January it was also considered
by overview and scrutiny panel on the
25th of January and there were no
recommendations to council cabinet has
been working with officers for many
months to develop the proposals most
members have been briefed informally on
the details that specifically arranged
budget briefing sessions in addition to
the normal channels Council has already
approved increases to fees and charges
which will generate an additional three
hundred and ninety thousand pounds
further income generation plans and
efficiency savings are set out in
Section seven the medium-term financial
strategy is set out in detail in annex
one there are as ever
substantial uncertainties over the next
four years including macro economic
uncertainties decisions still to be made
by government regarding local government
finance and the fair funding review
there are two minor Corrections to this
report as compared to the
one presented to cabinet in paragraph
413 the totals for 2019 20 and 2020 21
in Table five have been amended and in
paragraph six to the wording is now
shared amongst all major preceptors
rather than other preceptors council
taxa ceramic is recommended to be 226
pound 44 for a bandy property in 2018 19
which represents two point nine nine
percent increase this equates to a rise
in the TDC element of a bandy council
tax bill of six pound 57 a year in light
of the collaborative approach taken for
this year's budget I sincerely hope the
council approves this report in
anticipation of approval I would like to
emphasize the corporate approach taken
by all members of all groups we each
have our own policy objectives and we
all regret the need for cost savings but
approval would be a reminder to people
inside and outside of Thanet that all
its elected representatives want to do
the right thing for the people of Thanet
even when faced with challenging
decisions I move that council approves
these recommendations is there a second
our second lecture counselor Campbell
you had your hand up who would you like
to say something yes thank you chair yes
tonight from my newly positioned
front-row dress circle seat
I should be voting against this budget
not to seek to effect a change in this
administration for I believe that that
should take place at the ballot box and
hopefully next year it will my objection
to this budget is that this council kept
monies given to it by central government
that was supposed to be passed on to
Town Council's in order to in some way
compensate them for the council tech
discounts that the town councils are now
burdened with but this council TDC kept
it for themselves to the great despair
fit of the residents particularly mine
in Ramsgate Ramsgate residents will now
lose over 300 thousand pounds per year
that was once paid by central government
yet another example of austerity hitting
an area of deprivation on another issue
contained within this budget this
council will next year be part of a Kent
and Medway pilot that will see districts
in County keep the business rates
instead of receiving the ever
diminishing government revenue funding
this is called - the business rate of
retention scheme although the officer
has informed us that there is an
assurance that TDC will not be worse off
partaking in this pilot the details of
the formula and process for the
distribution of these monies has yet to
be agreed I am therefore tonight seeking
an assurance that when this has been
agreed that that deal is brought before
this council to ratify for although we
may not be worse off we may not be
getting we may not be as better off as
some much more wealthy districts let us
say for example in East Kent for as well
as for as we all know I've lost me place
the hours we all know there is a massive
disparity of wealth and affluence in
Kent
unfortunately we here in fact seem to
always be at the bottom of the pile
whilst other much more wealthy districts
benefit from the greater largesse of
Kent County Council at our expense
I believe if however the deal on the
form
is an executive decision and not one for
this fall counsel can I at least have
the assurance tonight that the deal can
be called in to overview and scrutiny
and will be allowed to be scrutinized in
full and in great detail thank you
Steve section one four one five one off
we saw reply to that yeah I think Thank
You chairman I can say that the decision
effectively has already been made to
join the club as I described
year-over-year scrutiny panel the the
pilot for Kent as a whole there has been
we did that on the basis that there was
we couldn't be any worse off by being in
the pilot than by not being in the pilot
whether or not members choose to receive
information in relation to the pilot as
the details materialized that's up to
members to decide but and how they want
to receive that information and as ever
happy to provide any information as and
when I receive it but in the form in
which that is taken in which format and
which forum receives that information is
up to members
council Johnson thank you very much
chairman and thank you to the officers
for what is always a very difficult
report to produce in difficult times
often influenced by what's happening all
over the country and central government
and I do appreciate the difficulties
however I'm a Margate Central Ward
councillor and it looks like we're
getting a kicking in our ward here the
first thing I see is that you had 630
responses just over 10 percent of the
people who are asked their opinions of
what they'd like us to do and that's
fairly poor response I'm grateful to
officers today for responses about
church fields and meeting Court which in
our award the issues around church
fields which are council housing
properties go back way to probably prior
to 2003 even and we've been asking for
work to be done for a very long time and
every time it's kicked into touch and
I'm told well we're going to do this and
we're going to do that and in Brendan
Ryan's time the money was allocated when
I was the leader here that money has
still not been spent there so I do need
a proper response a public response to
this one consultants apparently have
been employed or are about to be
employed and I've been told this one
before but this needs to be done it's
unfair in our residents meeting Court in
our ward the renowned surgeon yes please
to match the budget this is in the
budget it's not in these to are not in
the budget that's what I'm coming to it
Church fields should be in the budget
meeting quarter a figure of about ten
thousand pounds should be in the budget
and I saw officers today and I thought
it might have been under the radar I
couldn't see it under East Kent Housing
it is not in the budget I can't find it
and we had been working since last
summer on funding from meeting
courthouse regeneration safety yes you
email v1 I have done know what I'm
talking about
thank you I emailed officers today and I
saw mr. Willis today he's doing his best
for us but unless I mentioned this in
front of all members you won't know that
this is something that doesn't seem to
be accounted for I do hope you are
listening to this because how many years
have gone by when we've needed to sort
out Church fields and now we have
elderly people in meeting court very
concerned that the funding has not been
spent anyway let's move on to the rest
the kicking in our Ward 64,000 pounds is
a - here under 7.5 page 62 64 thousand
pounds to remove from the events budget
this is an area that depends on tourism
it's probably worth about 4 million to
us now
and you're removing money from Oakley
events budget in particularly the
Margate area in the villages the flowers
are - 15 as well so again something that
enhances our towns but the biggest kick
is to the Winter Gardens this - three
hundred and fifty thousand these are all
in one small Ward which happens to be
our ward and I would be failing in my
duty if I did not draw all members
attentions to this and another point in
this report is about enterprise zones
I've seen little movements as we were in
control of this council to do anything
about enterprise zones and you've missed
a big opportunity there Thank You
councillor Stewart Piper Thank You chair
I'd like to say on behalf of the Thani
independent you get group that we will
be supporting this budget proposal this
evening
I should however just like to make it
clear that we are not supporting it
because we are stupid or cast our votes
stupidly or irresponsibly in this
chamber we are supporting it because we
recognize the hard work done by mr.
Willis and his team under extremely
difficult circumstances to get us to
this point we are supporting it because
we recognize our legal responsibility to
produce a balanced budget so we are
happy to support this proposal and
hopefully to allay any fears the leader
may have of barbaric or political
emasculation or castrations with our
vote this evening
councillor Gregory doing one of those
thank you madam jail
madam Jim this report runs to a total of
107 pages including annexes and large
sections of the text in the gender items
six are replicated on at least eight
pages of this I think was two years ago
that so mr. Willis Whitman said he was
going to be looking at reducing the size
of this report so can I ask that serious
consideration is given to reducing the
worthiness of this report for next year
members will have noted that the capital
program has been reviewed and the
essential schemes for safety revenue
income and savings are prioritized it's
unfortunately in the current economic
climate that these are the only types of
projects that the council can afford and
again I think was two years ago I said
we should be reviewing all of the
projects anyway but I was told that we
couldn't change that because it would
look it would affect the council's
standing as as far as the community were
concerned well obviously it doesn't if
you ever got the money on the face of
this it appears a prudent budget with
income assumptions set on the low side
an assumed growth in the council text
base of Northpoint 5% appears cautious
when the base grew by two percent from
last year and needs to grow by the same
amount each year to meet the proposed
building targets for the next ten years
the lack of a new asset management plan
making it difficult to estimate future
capital receipts is mentioned more than
once in this report this must surely
become a top priority to manage the over
700 properties or freeholds held by the
council the 1.6 million pounds allocated
to help reduce the council costs for
finding alternative accommodation for
those in housing need is welcomed we
look forward to seeing the proposals of
where these units will be Alec will be
located it's important that members of
the public are aware that the increase
in the bandy council tax base of six
pounds 657 will be just over a tenth of
the total increase in council tax which
includes the police county and fire
Precepts this should be widely
publicized to our residents which is
good a great deal of work has obviously
gone into the proposals to meet the 2.8
million funding gap I'm sure members
will look forward to analyzing the
regular budget reports to cabinet
outlining the performance of these
savings plans madam chairman we
appreciate the efforts of
mr. Willis and his team and putting
forward this budget and we'll be happy
to support it
Thank You councillor wells yes thank you
madam chair I'm just to pick up
Canterbury's points first the asset
management panel I think water put
through cabinet only at the last cabinet
so it is on the way and it is moving
moving forward and of course I have been
a considerable asset sales on the back
to raise that capital of is required so
you know it is there it is is moving
forward and it is getting me available
to actually craft the rest of those
asset sales actually needs to be made
council Johnson Council Campbell's
comments are completely agree our
considerable sympathy with the position
that you find yourselves in as I suspect
you must find that the position that we
find ourselves in I'll just go back to
the the actual very basic position we
have at the start of this scenario that
we're dealing with here tonight which is
if you go back to 2012 22 million pounds
worth of revenue budget for this council
of which 11 million came directly from
central government
you look at 2019 or thereabout we're
talking about 16 and a half million
pairs worth of revenue which we have to
raise all locally and there's no point
in pretending otherwise something has to
give and in doing that and in being in
that position you know we have to make
very painful very doable decisions
nobody's picking on a particular or a
particular area although I have heard
tale over time of Ramsgate feeling
different from time to time so maybe
small gate soon
they are agonizing decisions they're
ones that we had to actually make and
the very last decision we made was the
most agonizing it was about the events
budget and it's not because we want to
do it's because actually we'd already
gots the stage where there were like to
be a number of staff redundancies and we
looked at all the other options and we
still had a gap to close and anybody
listening to the television news and the
radio news over the weekend and hearing
about Northamptonshire coming to a
shuddering halt herring gay in the
degree of chaos even Lord helpers Paul
Carter of Kent County Council radio for
this morning defending all the many
dozens of things he's done
make ends meet which I notice didn't
include the 15 percent rise in members
allowances but perhaps we should forgive
him there everybody up and down local
government in this country at this
moment is struggling to try and make
those balanced budgets work and it is
going to be a painful exercise over the
next few years as much as it has been
over the last few but we are in that
context in a better shape and a better
place than some of our colleague
councils over the rest of the country
because of the hard works been done
before by everybody in this chamber in
agreeing budgets over the last two or
three years thank you
can I hand out which counts return end
to sum up please
thank you madam chairman switch this
thing on a I don't know what you want me
to say but I think we've said everything
and I think we all know we're in a
predicament and we're doing the best we
can possibly I will now instruct the
monitoring officer to conduct the
recorded votes
Thank You chairman councillor Ashby Casa
Bainbridge kasib hayford that's a
Braidwood casa brim not present Casa
Buckley Casa Campbell Casa Glenn Coleman
cook Casa Keith Coleman cook Catholic
honor Casa Constantine Casa crow Brown
Casa Curran Casa Dawson Casa della Casa
Dennis Casa Dexter Casa Dixon counselor
Edwards counselor Evans souther Jeremy
Fairbrass Catalan Fairbrass counselor
Falcon counselor Fenner counselor game
counsel Ian Gregory Casa Grove Casa
hatin castle Hillman counselor house for
presents Castle Jay Jones Casa Johnston
Casa Larkin's councillor Martin council
a matter face council a messenger
councillor Parsons councillor Linda
Piper council the Reverend Stewart Piper
councillor Linda Potts
councillor Roy Potts councillor pew
councillor Rogers counselor is a key
councillor David Saunders councillor
Maeve Saunders councillor savage
catheter shank counts first amass much
thing counts of a tailor councillor
Tomlinson Casa Townend councillor
Venables casa wells thank you
that is past thank you
agenda item 9 changes to committees
panels on boards 2017 18 please refer to
the supplementary agenda number 1
proportion policy I call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect of the
options as outlined in the report ok I
understand from democratic services is
that the only preference for a breeze
put forward is for option 1 and other
leaders have said that they had no
particularly strong preference I
proposed option 1 and I've already
advised mr. Hughes of the changes that
are necessary for option 1 for Margaret
is there a seconder council Parker does
any member wish to propose an
alternative option do members agree
thank you
group leaders may wish to take this
opportunity to advise of changes to
their nominations to committees panels
and board for the remainder of 2017 18
council Wells has done his I call upon
councilor Beauford yeah I think we've
just got to add somebody to governance
and old it and a nominate council phew
I call upon counselor Reverend Piper
Thank You chair for planning counselor
John Buckley counsel Robyn Edwards
counselor Linda Piper counselor Gary
Taylor for licensing board committee
counselor Linda Potts counselor Roy pots
counselor Trevor Xiong overview and
scrutiny committee counselor John Dennis
counsel Rory pots counselor George Rowe
zeki governance and Audit Committee
counselor John Buckley counselor Bertie
Braidwood counselor Linda Piper
counselor George Rowe Zeki general
purposes committee counselor Robin
Edwards counselor Gary Taylor
excuse me Thank You Chet does any other
group leader wish to make any amendments
to their committee nominations thank you
that concludes the business of this
meeting of the council